step by step Ukraine's military
commander-in-chief says the country is
creating conditions to advance Sarah
mayorsk in the Donetsk region is one of
a handful of villages reclaimed since
the start of the summer offensive
it's hard they have pre-sighted zones
methodically destroyed roads as this 24
year old Marine Russia's defense
minister last month commented on their
well-constructed defensive lines and
firing positions former U.S ambassador
to Ukraine Bill Taylor says an earlier
start to the counter-offensive would
have benefited Ukraine but just wasn't
possible they were digging in deeply and
in depth and putting in the obstacles in
the minefields that we're now reading
about
um so had the ukrainians been able uh to
go on the on the offensive sooner it
would have given the Russians less time
to prepare it the Ukraine Indian
president told the BBC last month that
progress has been slower than desired
but added some people believe this is a
Hollywood movie and expect results now
it's not
foreign
the West has invested heavily with money
and weapons including a U.S donation of
cluster Munitions a weapon that while
banned by many countries could help
Ukraine break through those heavily
entrenched Russian lines the slowness of
the provide provision of some of that
Aid is a huge factor in why this
offensive is going as slowly as it is
fighter jets are Another Western promise
with training in Romania set to start
later this month it's unlikely they'll
be used in this counter-offensive
I think it's very inappropriate at best
for us for anybody in the west or
anybody outside of Ukraine to be
critical of uh of of Ukrainian military
decisions Ukraine meanwhile is hitting
Russian bridges in occupied areas and
tactical storage locations in support of
their counter-offensive Crystal
gomancing Global News London